first official Republican debate is
airing tonight on Fox it already has so
much buzz get this ladies and gentlemen
TBS is going ahead with a made-for-tv
movie about the debate I got a sneak
peek at the casting if it's okay I'll
just take a second I'd like to share it
with you first up one of the one of the
moderators for the debate Chris Wallace
will be played by Chris Parnell that
makes sense actually that's Brett smart
Marco Rubio the junior senator from
Florida will be played by young Fred
Savage
Fox News moderator Bret Baier will be
played by this Lego man his fellow
moderator megyn kelly will be played by
any of these other Fox news anchors you
decide which one former Florida Governor
Jeb Bush will be played by Sam the Eagle
from the Muppets Kentucky Senator Rand
Paul will once again be played by 90s
Justin Timberlake
wisconsin Governor Scott Walker will be
played by donkey from Shrek the
president of Fox News Roger Ailes will
be played by the Stay Puft Marshmallow
Man Donald Trump will be played by this
bullfrog in a way Ted Cruz Ted Cruz will
be played by Dobby the house-elf
that's where the goodness is and finally
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie will
of course be played by Mama June from
honey boo boo
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please